[Music]
hello yes much like oh yeah okay great
yes as mentioned today I'm going to be
talking to you all about big numbers so
these are numbers that are bigger than
what we can kind of naturally do in
JavaScript by default that's my Twitter
handle there if you want to find me
I was pretty late to the party in terms
of Twitter so the last letter of my
first name and last name kind of
collapsed but yeah you can find me there
just a bit of a warning there will be
some math in this talk it's kind of hard
spoke about big numbers without talking
about that but I'll try to keep it as
easy and kind of as light as I can so
firstly numbers you know what are their
characteristics what are the kind of
defining features about numbers so
firstly we want to be able to store some
value that then we want to retrieve at
some later point potentially printed out
on a user interface but really the
unique and defining characteristic of
numbers is the ability to do operations
on those numbers are these predefined
mathematical things so things like
addition subtraction multiplication and
division
now javascript uses it only has one
number type and it's a 64-bit
floating-point number the I Triple E 754
this is unique to JavaScript you'll find
it in other languages like Ruby Python
and Java so we're not alone in having
this type now let's help people look at
that so this is 64 bits here now the
first bit is what we use to control the
signs this is whether the number is
positive or negative the next 11 bits I
like to think of them at the scale this
is how big or small the number is and
then the last 52 bits control the actual
value of the number now I've got 52 bits
written there because it sort of has 53
bits in that it assumes that 53 bits but
the first bit is always 1 so we can
store 53 bits worth of information there
but we only have 52 bits and this number
system is very similar to scientific
notation if you've ever seen that which
you probably have so you have a value
then
28.1 - sometimes by some scale to give
us our result this is exactly how
floating-point numbers work as well now
I mention we have 53 bits and so
coincidence that the max value we can
store inside of these numbers is what
happens when we set all of those values
in the value component to 1 we get 2 to
the 53 minus 1 that's our maximum value
that we could store and it also happens
to be numbered max 8 integer if you've
seen that number around but you didn't
know where it kind of came from so at
the bottom of screen number dot max a
integer is what it is if we set all of
the exponent bits to 1 so the scale part
we get this huge number here which is
known as number dot max value but it's
kind of a bit useless for what we want
to do in that if you have a number say
in this case number dot max a integer
and you add 1 to it you get what you
expect but if you add 1 to that again
you're going to get something you didn't
expect it didn't do anything and it's
sort of all this weirdness when you
start to go above number dot max 18 to
jump so for our purposes we're going to
say that because the defining
characteristic of numbers was these
operations we really don't want to be
going above that number we have
unexpected consequences so that's where
javascript is now let's think about how
we could go bigger how it could push
numbers to both store values much bigger
than max safe integer as well as be able
to do operations on them now you might
be asking like why like why would I be
interested or care about big numbers and
it are very valid and practical use
cases for using big numbers so say if
you're dealing with big distances say
astronomical units or you're doing any
kind of accumulation of big historical
data so they're counting the amount of
characters in tweets over a period of
years you might start to run into these
problems as you start just keeping
piling counts on counsel on counts
another common use cases if you're
shifting decimal so they have a decimal
value and you want to shift it to become
an integer value that shifts you might
kind of hit into these these problems
but really it's kind of just a bit of
fun you know it's for us to see how far
we could push this idea how far we could
overcome the
limitation of JavaScript or 64-bit
floating-point numbers and it's also a
bit of a challenge for us as well how
cool learn a lot by trying to overcome
those barriers there's actually a lot of
different ways of doing big numbers I
put a repo up there I'll link it on
Twitter as well afterwards and it has a
few other ways of doing them and
hopefully after this talk you'll see
that there are probably lots of
different ways that I didn't even
explore about doing big numbers so let's
get into it
this is my first technique and it's a
slowly the most basic but very
interesting technique and that's
converting numbers into strings so say
we have the number 125 we simply convert
it to the string 125 and this is really
easy to do all we do is we take a number
and convert it to a string this is sort
of the format of that system by doing
this simple trick how big can we go so
say we had three slots the biggest value
we could store in three slots is 999 and
in a more general sense if we had n
slots we could store 10 to the N minus 1
that's has the biggest speakers store if
we had n slots which raises the question
well how long is a string you know how
how big can these things be and the
answer is today it's actually pretty
vague it's not sort of locked down and
expect anywhere but if you test it in
browsers and in node and things like
that you'll find that this is probably a
safe value to use ^ 27 that seems to be
pretty safe and consistent so that's
what we're using today but so you know
in year seven is hopefully going to be
cleaned up in that respective is going
to set it to to the 53 -1 ^ 53 minus 1
which is that number dot max safe
integer value we saw before but for
today we're going to be using 2 to the
power 27 so we have this new max value
of 10 to the N minus 1 but what is that
what does that even mean like how how
big have we gone now come up with this
analogy which I'll be using for the rest
of the talk as well so say we had a
sheet of paper and on that sheet of
paper we start writing numbers so in the
first line we write the number 0 sorry 1
then a thousand on the next line a
million on the line after that a billion
and so on and each Center we do each
line as a centimeter P main thing to
note is that each centimeter is a
thousand times bigger in value
a centimeter before it so with
JavaScript numbers we can get six
centimeters down this page and until we
hit that max value on max f integer
sorry if we use this string method it
would take four thousand four hundred
and seventy four kilometers worth of
paper to store this number which is
pretty staggering when you can see that
at each centimeter it's a thousand times
bigger in value than in centimeter
before it this is like a really simple
technique and we're just completely
blown away that max value that we have
before and to put it in sort of terms
that we can understand it's from here in
Berlin to England and back twice with
each centimeter being a thousand times
bigger than one before it this is a
little diagram I'm going to create a
table I'm going to keep referring to as
we go just to kind of record our
progress so by simply stretching to
decimal strings we've now got a huge
increase in scale but you might be
thinking that's great like we could now
saw these big values but really what we
cared about with numbers is the ability
to do operations so I think the screens
gone
oh yeah okay so say we wanted to do
addition with two strings so we have
this string 256 and 182 how do we even
begin to start doing addition with these
numbers well firstly we could look at
the first column on the right now we
want to add 6 & 2
and we could create some system where
the character 6 plus the character two
yields the character 8 and not actually
do any math but because there's a small
integer values we can probably just lean
on JavaScript numbers under the hood to
sort of do these small safe operations
until we'll do that for convenience so
if you have the number 6 and the number
2 yeah hey move down to the left and we
have 5 plus 8 which gives us 13 we've
got a bit of a problem because we can't
store 13 in one column so we do sort of
primary school mathematics technique
where we subtract 10 carry a 1 and write
the remainder in the current column so
now we write a 3 and we carry that one
over to the next column and then we move
down we have 1 plus 2 plus 1 which gives
us 4 and we were able to add these
strings which is pretty fun and what's
interesting is that I was actually kind
of a really nice algorithm we were just
looking at two numbers at a time and
it's constantly shifting down the number
all right let's take a look at
subtraction this one's a little bit
harder so say we have the number 4005
and i subtract 11 from it so we have 5
minus 1 which gives us 4 then we kind of
into this weird situation we want to
have 0 minus 1 we can't really do that
so we start what I like the cause like a
lookup phase so we start looking down
the number until we find something that
we can borrow something from so in this
case we found 4 we take 1 from that we
can carry a 10 back alright now we can
take something from that
so that becomes a 9 we carry the 1 over
and now we can do something we can take
10 from 1 from 10 which gives us 9 ok
then shifting down again we have 9 minus
0 which gives us 9 and 3 minus 0 is of 3
okay and we got our answer but that was
kind of gross right we have to we
started shifting down and then we do
this search and then we have to come
back and add the search again and if
these were really big numbers that this
could be extremely inefficient you might
be searching back and forth back and
forth a lot so that something is one of
K this was much different to what we
add with addition where we were simply
moving down two digits at a time so
there's something to keep in your mind
that that's sort of a pain point for
this system now let's look at
multiplication there with me there's not
too much heavy mass small ego okay
so multiplication we could write a
multiplication algorithm but really once
you have addition you can reduce
application for free so you can think of
multiplication as just doing addition in
a loop so we start with 0 we had 10 we
add 10 we add 10 and we're done we have
an answer what's cool about that is we
didn't need any kind of new math we
could just leverage that addition
function we already had immediately it's
not gonna be super performant but
doesn't really matter for now okay
division same kind of idea except now
it's going to keep looping we're going
to keep subtracting from this number
until we can't subtract anymore so say
we start of the number 6 we subtract 2
we subtract 2 we subtract 2 we can
subtract anymore and what we do is we
just count the amount of times of
acquisitive tracked and we can count
because we had that add function are we
created before and so the answer is 3
and so by having addition and
subtraction we were able to get division
and multiplication for free which is
pretty great so as soon as we create a
system with addition and subtraction we
can create one that has division and
multiplication as well so we did pretty
well we created a system which has a
huge new value as well as being able to
do this predefined mathematical
operations and the really cool thing is
actually built this system so again I
tweaked this Li at the end if you're
interested you can kind of have a play
with it and it works for decimals as
well I didn't go into those and negative
and positive values but it actually
works is the thing I want you to take
away from that I wrote here on my slide
notes do not use in production I haven't
really tested the performance or
anything like that but it's sort of
interesting if you want to have a look
at that so I'm now going to move to the
next technique which is binary strings
so this is the binary representation of
the number 118 it's an 8 bit
representation now the max value in this
system is 2 to the n minus 1 and minus 1
and with n being to power 27 and why
it's minus 1 is because I'm storing the
binary a 4
that called two's-complement I'll
explain why it's important in a sec so
now we've got a kind of big bigger value
than what we started with with numbers
but a smaller value than our base 10
system that's because we're now in a
base 2 system like each digit we can't
store as much information in there but
it's still 1,100 and sorry 1347
kilometers on this sheet of paper worth
of paper with every centimeter being you
know a thousand times bigger so it's
still very big number but let's take a
look at subtraction in this system so we
have the number 5 and the minus the
number 3 in binary and we know that it
is going to give us 2 and we can use
this method called the two's complement
to sort of model this in a different way
so firstly what we do is we flip the
bits and we add one and then we can
simply just add we can just add like we
would before so in binary addition 1+1
you carry the 1 and you leave a 0 so we
go over now we have 1 in this column we
have this carry situation again 1 plus 1
so we have 0 and carry the 1 now we have
1 plus 1 again we put 0 but we're
carrying a 1 kind of into this area that
we don't care about it's got the
overflow bit and this system you just
throw that bit away you don't care about
it and what's interesting for those who
kind of know binary is that we've ended
up with the number 2 so even though we
had this subtraction problem we were
able to model it using addition so we
started the subtraction we flip the bits
oh you can see the animation back on and
so we actually ended up looking at it
like this we've been able to model
subtraction as if we were doing addition
which is really nice it's really nice
kind of a way of looking at the problem
let's go bigger with we've looked at
binary strings where can we go from here
let's double get hexadecimal strings
okay so that's the one string so
hexadecimal is representation of the
number 126 in hexadecimal and Texas
really simple it's just a mapping of 0
through 9 and 0 through 9 and A through
F is 10 through 15 so you can store 16
possible values in each string each slot
of a string and so now we have this new
max value of 16 to the N minus 1 which
is bigger than what we had in decimal
but it's going to have a pretty probably
a bad subtraction story but we're moving
now in the direct
of trying to chase bigger and bigger
numbers so this one is now five thousand
three hundred eighty seven kilometers
worth of paper but what I wanted to have
a look at with hexadecimal is we said we
could sort 16 possible values in each
slot of the string which goal is the
question what can we store in a slot of
a string what's a what's the maximum
thing which is during that which leads
me to my final technique for Strings
which is 16-bit strings and to
understand this technique we understand
heed to understand how strings work a
little bit better and to understand
strings we need to understand unicode so
unicode is really simple it's just a map
of symbol to integers or symbols to code
points and that's all it is so code
points they just decided arbitrarily
that these symbols map to these integers
that's all it is and there's about 1.1
million of them now JavaScript as a
language has decided that it's going to
treat every 16-bit unit of a string as
one character and I'm going to show you
what that means so let's start with this
string here the letter e it equates to
the unicode integer of 101 now you can
pull that out from the string using code
pointer and it's going to give you that
integer back but you'll see if it's in
hexadecimal and the Unicode kind of
stream sense it equals slash u 0 0 6 5
and has a length of 1 and this will be
true for any character that has a
Unicode code point between 0 and ^ 16
things get interesting when we start to
move two characters that are bigger then
^ 16 in integer value so in this case we
have an emoji which equates to a code
point and you'll see that it actually
equals in JavaScript it's two different
unicode strings and has a length of two
so even though visually to us it seems
like it's one character according to
JavaScript as a language that we deal
with it's two and this gets even more
crazy when you start to introduce things
like modifiers where according to
unicode it's too huge huge numbers but
javascript needed for 16-bit compartment
strings to represent that
so even though it looks to us like one
character jobs just calling it for so
really the biggest things that we could
store inside one slot of a string is
anything from 2 0 2 to the power 16 so
we have 2 to the power 16 possible
different things that we could store in
each of these slots which to put into
perspective if we looked at the piece of
paper in terms of kilometers it's with
each centimeter being a thousand times
bigger than a centimeter before it it
would be from here back to my hometown
in Sydney and Matt a little bit back
again or around 21,000 kilometers with
how much how much paper we would need to
record that value but what about
operations you know if we have the
string cash plus dollar what does that
give us well we sought its method before
where we could pull out the integer
value so we can just simply pull that
integer value out through the addition
and if we really wanted to we could
actually save that result back into a
Unicode string so if you didn't know
hash plus dollar equals capital G till
so I've got a pretty big increasing
scale it's kind of pushed just to the
limit of what we could do with strings
so here we go from here well let's have
a look at a race so firstly we had a
string I've been very deliberate with my
language in saying that a string has
slots now we could also think of our
array of characters so we can think of
strings and row characters but we also
have arrays in JavaScript so technically
we could store anything we want in one
of these slots we don't have to score it
as one character and then the kind of
conclusion of that is we could store one
of these super strings that we created
in each slot of an array so how long is
an array well
array is 2 to 3 minus 1 so you know
which means our new max value is this
huge thing here to put into perspective
how much paper we'd need to store that
number you have to go from the Sun to
Pluto I like mentioning Pluto because
the planet when I was young and I like
keeping it relevant so from here to
Pluto from Sun sorry to put a 135 times
that's how much paper you would need so
yes it's about 3 trillion kilometers
with a paper with each centimeter being
a thousand times bigger
2-centimeter before these numbers just
like I can't even come and process them
and this was just one level deep arrays
right we're just looking at a ray that
has strings you know there's something
stopping us from having arrays of arrays
or arrays of arrays of arrays and the
numbers start to get absurd I couldn't
even really think of any good analogies
for them anymore now something you might
have been thinking about this whole time
and definitely with the arrays is memory
right
can we actually store these things so
let's have a look we start with this
string we know we have 16 bits per slot
now they might do some optimization on
the hood but let's assume that 16 bits
per slot we have to the 27 slots so and
the amount of bits is about 2 billion
bits or 268 megabytes to store one of
these strings and if we're trying to
store an array we have 268 megabytes per
slot to the 32 slots about 1 million
terabytes to store one of these things
so definitely something you don't want
to be doing all right so we're going to
stick with this you know 215 megabytes
is kind of something we can probably
deal with now what we could do is if we
were running a node by default you get
about 1.7 gigabytes on a 64-bit machine
you could increase the amount of memory
you know your node process has to kind
of work with these things more naturally
but we're starting to do so probably
going down an approach that we shouldn't
be going down so let's take a step back
let's think about what we've learned
from looking at this string approach to
doing that so absolutely learnt that if
we we can do almost any operation if we
can add if we're using a binary system
if we can add we can kind of do lots of
different operations and we can add two
numbers we can add numbers together
potentially really big numbers we only
need to look at two digits of that
number at a time so just kind of looking
down the column shifting to the right
shifting to the left sorry okay let's
take those learnings of apply in
somewhere else so say we have this file
and it's encoded in utf-8 which means
you have 8/5 a flexible 8-bit encoding
okay now in this file we have the binary
string and it's huge it's like 10
gigabytes big much bigger than we could
store in memory at once and let's say we
have two of those strings two of those
files sorry we could open a stream
to those files this is sort of like a
live connection to the file without
reading anything in and then we create a
buffer we're just going to read in one
byte at a time from each of these files
and this is why it was important that it
was utf-8 because 0 & 1 fall in the
first 8 bits we'll be able to read in
one digit at a time which is what we
wanted to do we just want to read in one
digit at a time from these files so we
read in one digit of time we do the
operation we might save the overflow if
there is one in memory for a little bit
and then we output that one byte at a
time to an output file and this is
pretty cool this means we could actually
add incredibly big numbers that you know
we could never really store in memory by
just kind of just looking at two little
things at a time and just adding them
and kind of passing it on I actually
built this one as well as in the repo if
you want to check that out and because
think of it like this so you have two
input streams so you get two digits a
100 zero you add them you get one and
then you save it to the output file and
it's kind of keep doing that process and
it's very similar to what we had before
we just shift just keep shifting down we
can do this on numbers that I'm a much
bigger McCann store memory so now this
table starts to break down right our
limiting factor is not I'm sorry I know
you probably can't see the bottom of
screen right now but I've just written
infinite right your limiting factor is
how much memory you have on your machine
which is a pretty big increase in scale
I didn't even bother to figure out how
big in terms of kilometers that would be
but we could take it further right we're
limited by our own machine well what if
we weren't even limited by our own
machine what if we instead distributed
this number across multiple machines so
no one machine could ever see the whole
number at once but all these different
machines had pieces of the number you
know we could store them using that and
we could also create some sort of
protocol to do distributed operations
because we don't actually need to see
the whole piece of the number at once to
do an operation you only need to see two
digits we could distribute how we do
this addition across multiple nodes and
then stream that output to someone who
cares about it right so now a limiting
factor isn't even our machine it's how
many machines we have access to
so we went big we weren't really big you
know we would probably went bigger than
you thought we were going to go today
limiting factor being the amount of
machines that you have and we actually
learned a lot from implementing a number
system using strings which you know you
might have thought was a bit strange to
start with and we're able to take those
learning some of the kind of nicer
patterns that we found about dealing
with strings and what I would apply that
in a completely different way to build
it on the system that you know maybe we
didn't think about when we first started
and so my big takeaway from today is
don't be afraid to try something a
little bit different you know it might
you might actually get some learnings
from that that you can apply to some
other problem or to you know find some
solution that you didn't even think
about when you first started yeah so you
never know what you'll learn and where I
will lead you
before I finish is wondering know like a
good mate of mine Stephen campaign who's
a math teacher really helped me a health
is a lot of the heavier math this talks
a big shout to him and also all my
amazing colleagues at lassen is like
here I've been chewing off for the last
few months
like wrapping my head around some of
these problems if you do want to use big
numbers in production there is a library
you can kind of use that also if you are
interested they're looking at putting
infinite precision integers into
JavaScript there's a draft stage to
proposal kind of funky pub you can check
that out great
thanks everyone
[Applause]